je regrette je regrette d'avoir à
or d autant d'importance
des autres et de ne pas mettre plus
écoutés je suis heureuse d'avoir passé
tous ces beaux moments avec mes proches
parce que très vite j'ai pris conscience
qu'il fallait en profiter
tous les matins j'ai vécu un instant de
bonheur tous les matins en ouvrant mes
volets et en contemplant mon jardin j'ai
vécu un instant de bonheur
ce que j'aimerais transmettre à mes
enfants avant de partir qu'il faut vivre
vivre et aimer en commençant par soi
même
bonjour je m'appelle adeline et je suis
art-thérapeute
elle elle s'appelle capucine et c'est
une fée une fée des fleurs moi je suis
un être humain un être humain
profondément vulnérables est un parfait
elle c'est une fée et c'est aussi ce que
l'on appelle une étoile l'association
l'aîné toile a été créé il ya 15 ans par
sandra monié et nous sommes aujourd'hui
une étoile à intervenir en france
les hommes des femmes des fées et des
lutins gesvres dans des services
d'oncologie de soins palliatifs et en
fait ça n'est pas moi qui intervient
dans ses services c'est elle
capucine et mon dispositif art
thérapeutique
alors vous me direz pourquoi il fait
parce que nous faisons le pari d'ouvrir
aux patients une relation coeur à coeur
une relation spontanée lumineuse et vous
pourriez me dire mais quel effet ça
peut-être que lorsque ce personnes un
gendre dans une chambre la proposition
qui est faite c'est l'ouverture d'un
espace très particulier l'ouverture d'un
espace intime profond d'un espace de
ressources d'un espace que peut-être
tous les êtres humains on est au sein
duquel peut se vivre des moments de joie
avec pendant ce qui est en train de se
vivre dans l'instant présent
alors être une étoile c'est quoi être
une étoile c'est déjà se mettre au
service de l'autre
pour moi il est important de partir du
principe que ce que je sais c'est que je
ne sais rien c'est l'autre qui est en
face de moi qui a conscience de ses
besoins ou qui peut avec un certain
soutien en prendre conscience
c'est lui qui sait ce qui lui est
nécessaire pour vivre cette expérience
qui se prépare mon travail à moi c'est
d'ouvrir un espace pour que ça puisse
émerger le travail d'une étoile est un
travail profondément spirituelle mais
pas religieux je ne projette jamais mon
système de croyances sur le patient du
rencontre
et plus encore je me laisse toucher
parce qu'il est au moment où je le
rencontre se mettre à la rencontre ce
maître service dans la rencontre de
l'autre c'est quoi et bien c'est déjà
allé le rencontrer et c'est souvent dans
une chambre d'hôpital pour moi c'est
certainement lui ouvrir cet espace là et
puis soutenir ce qui est déjà au travail
chez le patient soutenir ce mouvement
qui est déjà le mouvement du départ
lorsque je rencontre pierre il est en
fin de vie
pierre à 42 ans l'équipe soignante
m'indique qu'il serait nécessaire que
j'aille le rencontrer pourquoi pierre ne
semble pas prêt à décoller et oui
capucine parle de décollage pierre ne
semble pas prêt et l'équipe me dit il
sans dans une grande tristesse peut-être
que toi tu pourra l'aider quand j'entre
dans sa chambre il me trouve belle
enfin il la trouve belle assez vite il
va laisser émerger sa tristesse est
assez vite
capucine va lui faire une proposition
qu'elle fait souvent en lui demandant
est ce qu'il y à un endroit que tu aime
particulièrement
un endroit qui vraiment au fait du bien
oui dit pierre mon jardin à ton jardin
et si tu me faisait visiter ton jardin
avec toi et nous voilà partis
intérieurement en respirant et pierre me
fait visiter son jardin
la rocaille les plantes grimpantes les
parterres tout cela lui a demandé des
heures de travail
et puis nous arrivons à la glycine je
vous laisse imaginer le parfum me
glisser la beauté de la glycine en fleur
et pierre me dit un stallone ou la
prends une chaise et respirons la
glycine ensemble la proposition que
capucine fait aux passions à ce moment
là c'est de lui dire et si tu décides
est qu'au moment de décoller ce soit
près de ta glycines et si tu décides est
que ces deux temps que jardin que tu
vivras ce moment à windy pierre à c'est
une bonne idée ça me fait beaucoup de
bien imaginer que je veux me
télétransporté intérieurement à cet
endroit là au moment où je devrais faire
le passage comme un vous me diriez ça
semble simple et finalement c'est très
conceptualiser l'intervention d'une
étoile
qu'est ce qui se passe à ce moment là je
ne peux pas empêcher un patient mourir
mais je peux l'accompagner travailler
avec lui à ce que ce chemin qu'il est en
train de parcourir c'est clair la devise
des étoiles c'est si on ne peut pas
changer la vie alors on peut changer le
regard qu'on porte sur elles d'autres
patients vivent ces instants
différemment un jour j'ai rencontré
jacques jacquet dans une grande colère
une colère d'allemands explosive qu'elle
arrose partout le service les soignants
ses proches sont les mouz et les équipes
ne savent plus comment prendre jacques
évidemment dans ces moments là c'est à
moins qu'on me demande un petit peu des
deux
lorsque je rencontre jacques ça ne se
passe pas mieux avec moi qu'avec les
autres il faut savoir que jacques est un
ancien soignant il était médecin
urgentiste et parapentiste assez vite
jacques vabre rejeté sa colère sur
capucine et c'est une bonne chose aussi
capucine étant une fée elle peut dire à
jacques je peux tout accueillir d'asie
envoie tout ce que tu dois envoyer je
peux tout accueillir jacques finira
quand même le troisième entretien par
lui hurler dessus une question vraiment
forte
une vraie question qui lui l'animent à
ce moment là pourquoi c'est moi qui
crèvent et pas toi et ça fait il y aura
répondu je t'aime je t'aime à chaque
instant de nos rencontres
je t'aime quel que soit ton et à je
t'aime quand tu mets en colère je t'aime
quand tu souffres je t'aime tout le
temps je ne vous dirai pas que cela
complètement apaisé jacques par contre
ça lui a ouvert un espace au sein duquel
sa colère a pu se déposer s'exprimer
dans l'instant d'après capucine n'a pu
accompagner jacques à respirer et même
intérieurement encore un voyage
intérieur à pratiquer le parapente ce
que je vous dis là est finalement une
incarnation féerie d'un concept bien
connu des psys qui s'appelle le holding
et qui a été développé par mini cote
dans les années 70 le portage porte et
l'autre le porte est complètement
totalement
quel que soit ce qu'il est en train de
vivre peut lui permettre de se déposer
de s'accueillir et finalement de
traverser peut être ce qu'il est en
train de traverser alors me direz-vous
mais est ce que ça marche à tous les
coups
à votre avis est-ce que ça marche à
chaque fois et bien la réponse est non
évidemment et non ça ne peut pas
fonctionner à chaque fois parce que
chaque être humain est unique et qu'à
cet instant de sa vie
chaque être humain va avoir des besoins
particuliers et singuliers en tant
qu'humaine
j'aurais envie de rajouter que c'est
certainement cela qui participe à la
beauté de l'être humain donc un patient
peut dire non à la rencontre avec des
piscines qu'est ce qui peut faire qu'un
patient refuse alors on l'a entendu
peut-être que ça n'est pas son besoin et
puis peut-être aussi que dans le fait de
dire non un patient ne subit pas il agit
un patient qui est hospitalisé dans un
service de soins palliatifs ou
d'écologie subit souvent le patient a la
sensation de subir la douleur de la
maladie du traitement des horaires
expérience peut-être qu'il est en train
de vivre et donc à un moment où il va
jeter il a fait c'est une manière pour
lui certainement d'agir quelque chose et
de reprendre une position d'acteur
l'expérience de la mort est une
expérience qui depuis longtemps mais
l'humanité au travail pour moi lorsqu'un
patient dit non mon travail c'est de
l'accueillir à s'éteindre l'a jamais je
ne porte pas de jugement à ce moment je
trouve ça même très intéressant parce
qu'un patient qui vient me dire non
m'ouvre une porte et il me permet
finalement de transmettre au tour aux
équipes à sa famille que peut-être il
n'y a pas de bonne façon de mourir que
peut-être chaque être humain devra
cheminer vers ce passage et chaque être
humain devra négocier les virages qui
vont y conduire peut-être s'en fait
peut-être s'en fait mais pour moi avec
toutes les ressources nécessaires pour
traverser ce moment une de mes
hypothèses en tant qu une étoile c'est
que si on sait net on sait mourir si
l'être humain c'est arrivé il a
forcément le programme pour partir alors
on pourrait se dire mais finalement
qu'est ce qui peut nous permettre de
faire ce passage le mieux du monde
si la main n'est pas un pas facile elle
reste une expérience universelle nous
devrons tous emprunté ce chemin je ne
sais pas vous mais vous me permettrait
d'avoir une hypothèse mon idée c'est que
peut-être plus où se relie à londres
mieux on part mon idée c'est que
peut-être plus on se relier à ceux qui
nous aiment à ceux qu'on aime
à nos instants de vie et peut-être que
mieux vous pourra découler
j'aimerais vous parler de claire clair à
41 ans elle a deux enfants de 10 ans
lorsque j'entre dans sa chambre elle est
sur le départ
elle est déjà inconsciente ces filles
sont présents ainsi que ses parents
l'ambiance est extrêmement lourde
mais pour une fait ça n'est pas un
problème lorsque j'entre dans cette
chambre
assez vite je me rends compte que
peut-être que l'idée de transmettre et
de partager serait une idée adapté et
capucine va donc proposer une chaîne
d'amour une chaîne d'amour c'est je me
mets au service de la famille ghislain
pour qu'à chaque inspiration et à chaque
expiration en tenant la main de cette
patiente en tenant la main d'une de ses
filles qui est à côté de moi à chaque
inspiré à chaque expire ce qui peut se
diffuser
c'est l'amour que j'ai pour l'autre
alors capucine solidement ancré dans ses
chaussures de faits a pu accompagner ses
enfants et ses parents un inspire et à
chaque inspiration pense à tout l'amour
que tu as
pour cette maman ou pour ta fille et à
chaque expiration transmet comme si tout
ce sentiment passé dans chacune de ces
cellules inspire et expire parce que
parfois quand on ne peut pas ou qu'on ne
peut plus dire à l'autre quand on ne se
sent pas en capacité de le faire
peut-être qu'une des voies s'est incarné
respirer faire vivre ce lien qui nous
unit souvent la question qui m'est posée
c est comme tu fais quand tu fais pour
intervenir dans ces espaces là et bien
je dirais deux choses la première c'est
que je ne fais pas
en fait je ne fais rien je suis la
seconde c'est que les patients que je
rencontre sont de grands enseignants à
ce titre j'aimerais vous parler de
camille camille je l'accompagné de l'eau
- de sa première hospitalisation à son
décès elle avait 25 ans camille a appris
deux choses
elle m'a appris que ce qui est
tranquille à l'intérieur et souvent
tranquille à l'extérieur et puis elle
m'a appris que même lorsque le chemin
qu'ont emprunté lourd
il est possible de vivre de grands
moments de bonheur
par exemple un moment de bonheur un 24
décembre
je rouge la rencontre et jours ce jour
là on a pu écouter de la musique
la grande musique de la musique qui lui
faisait du bien et profiter de cet
instant mon hypothèse c'est que l'être
humain trouve le plus de l'apd sa
puissance dans sa vulnérabilité
plus je me sent vulnérable plus je me
sens toucher parce que le patient est en
train de vivre est peut-être plus
je vais pouvoir le porter et la
compagnie à partir et à vivre ce qu'il
doit vivre
alors oui je me relie aux patients bien
compagne oui il me touche et je fais le
pari que plus je me relis à moi et m
et mieux les choses se passent une
étoile c'est donc ça un autre
authentique profond qui se connecte le
plus possible à l'autre pour
l'accompagner à partir avant de vous
quitter
j'aimerais vous proposer une expérience
je vais vous inviter à fermer les yeux
ou à vous concentrer sur une civière
vous et vous invite à vous laisser
guider par votre souffle et exclut la
cites le souffle et craintif et à cet
instant exalead en cinq sets paroles que
vous avez envie de prononcer le culot
laisser émerger cette personne à
laquelle vous avez quelque chose
d'essentiel accuse un peu le coup de cet
endroit mais l'humeur découvrir cette
idée vous revient souvent
est ce qu'on vient de notre temps vous
avez rêvé de réaliser
laissez le venir à votre esprit je vous
invite à cet instant à prendre un
engagement de la wsk à réaliser ce
projet admire cette tarde à venir tuer
café fait à expiration
ressentez ce que ça provoque sur cette
piste et je sais que je suis heureux
d'avoir caché
prenez une robe d'inspiration revenez
dans l'iss et la mort durant un instant
et la vie beaucoup plus à leur vivant
[Applaudissements]